now that we have the concepts down let's
go through some actual code you can find
a link to the repository that contains
this application in the instructor notes
so here we have a Pizza ordering
application you can click on this Add
Pizza button here to add pizzas and each
pizza has its own unique number we can
also click any of these X buttons to
remove the pizzas and you'll notice that
if we add a couple more pizzas
it starts off where we left off seven
eight now let's take a look at the
actual code behind this
more specifically the model that's
driving it now before we dive into the
JavaScript I'll just mention that we
have an HTML file here and we've also
got a style dot CSS file right here you
can go through this code on your own if
you'd like to figure out how it works
but it's relatively simple just some
HTML Dom nodes and some CSS selectors
and properties the JavaScript is where
the heart of this application allows we
have var data and if we scroll down we
also have var octopus and far view let's
take a look at the model up here now in
this application the model is just
called data it doesn't necessarily have
to be called model per se but that's its
function and you can see that our model
is just a simple object with a couple
properties inside it's got a property
for the last ID of the pizza and an
array of pizza objects with such a
simple example it may not seem obvious
why we want to separate this out but
bear with me sometimes our model isn't
so simple and we'll see examples of this
in the near future